have you seen your favorite Harry Potter
actor totally lose it can we stop the
interview is that okay from Emma
Watson's fits of laughter to Daniel
Radcliffe's tears and plenty of
nostalgia these cast members have had
some emotional moments in interviews
over the years and we've got all their
most dramatic moments Daniel Radcliffe
shed some Tears while talking about the
cast and crew of Harry Potter and it's
easy to see why the first film of the
franchise Harry Potter and the Sorcerer
Stone premiered in 2001 at the time
Daniel who famously played the titular
wizard was 12 Harry Potter and the death
Le Hallows part two the final film
premiered a decade later in 2011 it's
difficult to imagine the kind of impact
working on these movies must have had on
its young stars during the reunion
special in 2022 Radcliffe spoke a little
about why and the moment is touching the
crew in these films were unbelievable
there are people on these films that are
foundational to who I am as a person
through tears Radcliffe explained that
he loves his adult life and career and
he owes it all to his start in Harry
Potter so yeah it was a very good 10
years those tears of nostalgia from
Daniel Radcliffe were surely contagious
for some of us but Emma Watson's
laughter is contagious to everyone
during an interview about Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows the typically
totally in control Watson who famously
played Hermione Granger found herself in
a fit of the giggles I was told I wasn't
allowed to tell my friends that I had
the role that was basically impossible
for me cuz I was desperate to tell
everyone I knew while it's not clear
exactly what hit the star's Funny Bone
she struggled to keep a straight face
for the rest of the interview and it's
nearly impossible not to laugh along
with her I'm so sorry it's the okay can
I stop for just two seconds and the
laughs from this cast certainly didn't
stop with Emma Watson in one interview
alongside Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson
and rert grin who played Ron Weasley
talk about just how difficult it was for
them to kiss on screen thanks to their
sibling like relationship in real life I
just remember your face getting closer
and closer to every time you talk about
this you make it sound like an actual
horror show wasn't that bad I know and
from the sound of it this moment was
just as funny when it was really
happening on set everyone wants to be on
set cuz everyone was like this is going
to be good clearly this cast tends to be
an open book in interviews there was one
moment though when Daniel Radcliffe
refused to share a certain detail and it
was all thanks to a not safe for work
present from rert Grint on the Jonathan
Ross show Radcliffe explained that rert
grin once gifted him a trumpet that he
himself engraved what did he engrave on
it could you tell us was it too personal
I no I think it was just abuse that's
all he writes when he writes cards to us
and I don't think I can say on we can
only imagine the strange trumpet
Radcliffe now has sitting somewhere in
his home Daniel bradcliff may have felt
like he couldn't reveal his buddy's
hilarious message on TV but he revealed
quite a lot on the big screen in the
projects that followed Harry Potter and
the way one interviewer brought this up
I've noticed as a you've got a pattern
now of of nakedness yes left the star in
stitches do you think you might be
making up for lost time of the
relatively pg8 years of Harry Potter in
terms of nudity well I know but thank
God there was no nudity in the first few
films clearly even after Decades of
interviews some questions can still
leave these cast members surprised it's
not that I feel like oh I'll like shock
people by getting naked it's not
something I seek out Ivana Lynch played
Luna love good in the franchise Who
belongs to the Hogwarts house Ravenclaw
in one interview she took the Potter
more quiz to discover her house in real
life and let's just say she was very
pleased with her result
Gryffindor but also like not surprised
so while she may be a Ravenclaw on
screen she's a Gryffindor at Heart from
one star's affirming quiz result to one
that didn't come quite so easily Tom
Felton who played Draco Maloy got
competitive while taking a quiz during
an interview if anyone could Ace the
most impossible Harry Potter quiz it
would be one of the movie stars but it
was impossible after all how many Harry
Potter characters can you name in one
minute
hook um uh Dobby James Potter Lily
Potter SE snake oh c not as easy as it
sounds how many did I get seven very T
it's clear from cast interviews that
these Stars had a blast filming these
movies regardless of how many Harry
Potter characters they can name and
while we had a hard time not laughing
along with Emma Watson her tears at the
reunion were just as contagious to folks
watching like her onscreen bestie Daniel
Radcliffe she too got emotional while
talking about the franchise specifically
her love for the actors who played the
hair and Ron to her Hermione they was so
kind and they both took the
responsibility of it really seriously
and I appreciated that so much working
with Radcliffe and rert Grant was most
amazing experience and that I can't
really explain to you like that's such
good people which interview Outburst was
your favorite would you like to see
another reunion with this cast let's
talk about it in the comments and for
more videos like this one like And
subscribe to the
things